uh the a little bit of cloud cover let's
check it out overnight we are seeing
temperatures in the 60s we're actually
going to watch the clouds increase
throughout the day today and you'll see
that we are anticipating the wind to
build up but right now nothing's going
on so this is our camera on top of the
bank of america building up the rainbow
in the 95. uh these are the flags that
we zero in on when it gets super windy
out there and we are talking about the
gusty winds picking upwards of 20 miles
an hour during the day today and also
during the day tomorrow our current
temperature officially at las vegas is
67 but let's see what's happening in
your neighborhoods hanging on to let's
see i thought i saw a 65 yeah there it
is up in summerlin and centennial hills
certainly cooler up at kyle canyon
hanging on close to 70 for nellis the
strip and the green valley and henderson
i think these numbers are going to drop
a degree or two before the sun comes out
we start turning things back around man
is chilly up in ely at 39 so reno seeing
the beginnings of this cold front that
we're going to get more right now and
then working its way into the southern
nevada area 82 right now for death
valley take away 30 good morning beatty
with your 52. so we made 83 yesterday
we're going to kick it up a couple of
more to 85 today our current temperature
the low so far again that's a few
degrees above normal so what's going on
we got a little bit of a double whammy
as we mentioned here's the beginning of
that front that will be impacting reno a
little bit later or another wave further
to the south so look for increasing wind
and chances for rain along with cooler
temperatures could even call it a triple
whammy meantime we showed some video a
little bit a go about a water water
rescue from some flooding in northern
alabama that area of low pressure is now
rotating to northern illinois into the
chicago area your eight day forecast
we'll call it building clouds and 85 but
a 10 degree temperature drop with gusty
winds storms around mostly is going to
be wind and cooler temperature event
then that gets out of here for a very
nice southern nevada weekend
temperatures below normal another storm
system even more impactful in terms of
wind and chances for rain possibly
dropping the temps into the 60s next
week maybe overnight lows in the 40s